a gift for autism Foundation gala is
back for another year of raising funds
and fun I should add on Allegiant Phil
let's welcome Kate lowenhart Fisher to
the show she is here to give us all the
details welcome thank you thank you so
much for having me please I'm so excited
to tell everybody about this I was there
last year for the black and silver this
year we're wearing blue tell everybody
why and what the foundation does well oh
the uh the blue color a lot of people
associate blue with showing support and
awareness of autism right so we decided
to go in the blue Direction this year
and I love it because people can
interpret that however they want right
okay we gotta find the cute blue dress
to support all right now this is the
12th year what can people expect from
this year in particular what's changing
up this year oh remember last year was
fabulous yes it was this year is even
better okay all right so we're going to
have a huge crowd we anticipate that
it's going to be even bigger wow than
last year it was a great turnout yes
we're going to have fantastic Music
Entertainment a great dinner we're
seeing visuals now of last year
flowing and we'll have an auction and
it's really it's it's spectacular I
don't think there's another charitable
event in Las Vegas that's like it I
agree with you last year the Raiders
players were involved in the auction are
we going to have some celebrity guests
too so you're giving away all the
secrets we've got to be there to find
out yes okay okay and how much money did
you raise last year what's the goal this
year oh our goal this year one million
dollars to support our efforts oh that
is incredible so last year we did a
great job yeah this community raised
about 600 000 which is tremendous for
our work and this year we're going to
aim even higher okay I know you guys can
do it I know you guys can do it Las
Vegas community and how involved are the
kids at the galley because last year I
really enjoyed getting to talk to them
watching them on stage giving their
speeches exactly we're going to be
telling a lot of those stories again we
have some new faces and new kiddos to
share and I always say you're going to
you're going to cry oh and I was
laughing I was crying I will be inspired
so you'll get a lot of that connection
to those stories for sure now how can
people get tickets and join us because I
will be there in my blue if we have any
left oh that's right we do we have a few
we have a few so I would say go to
grantagift.com okay backslash events and
you could still still time to register a
little more time a little time to
register and get your outfit get your
blue thank you so much Grant to give
Gallo Thursday October 20th 5 30 to 9
p.m at Allegiant stadium football field
it is so cool it's so fun such a great
cause grantagift.com events for your
tickets